bonsoir samantha vous êtes donc à
abidjan comment s'est déroulée cette
journée
alors aujourd'hui cet après midi plutôt
l'ancien président henri konan bédié a
tenu une conférence de presse aux côtés
de pascal affi n'guessan qui est le
leader d'une frange du f pays le front
populaire ivoirien c'est le parti fondé
par laurent gbagbo
le grand absent de cette élection tous
les deux comme prévu n'ont pas voté et
ils ont réaffirmé qu'ils ne
reconnaissaient pas ce scrutin du 31
octobre
un scrutin sous haute sécurité marquée
par des heurts dans le sud du pays dans
les principaux fiefs de l'opposition
douze régions classées en rouge ou les
votes ont été empêchés dix régions
classées en orange ou là où c'est encore
assez tendu par exemple à gagnoa à
l'ouest le fief du f pays on a noté des
affrontements intercommunautaires
plusieurs maisons ont été incendiées à
adzopé à l'ouest des affrontements entre
manifestants et forces de l'ordre ont
été relevés et puis ici à abidjan nous
nous trouvons dès la fin de matinée des
échauffourées ont éclaté à un blockhaus
proche du quartier chic de cocody
là où le président sortant alassane
ouattara candidat pour un troisième
mandat eh bien à voter à 11h ce matin
et puis à yopougon kouté une commune
populaire d'abidjan on a noté la
présence d'hommes armés de machettes la
population s'est terrée chez elle et au
moment où on a quitté notre hôtel pour
rejoindre la commission électorale est
bien au niveau de la terrasse on pouvait
observer une épaisse colonne de fumée en
provenance justement de cette commune de
yopougon abidjan où aujourd'hui durant
toute cette journée la vie s'est
quasiment arrêté une ville morte
ce soir est la vie reprend peu à peu son
cours dans les quartiers populaires au
total 35 mille hommes étaient mobilisés
pour sécuriser plus de 22 mille bureaux
de vote qui ont fermé leurs portes
je propose d'écouter une réaction que
nous avons recueillis ce matin du
premier ministre ivoirien hamed bakayoko
mais la sécurité à 100% n'existe pas
quand vous avez dix mille bureaux de
vote
et vous en mettez trois t3 agents pas
durer 2 mois de ça fait trente mille et
devant des populations qui sont
manipulés qui arrive souvent à 53 cents
nous avons insisté auprès de nos hommes
pour qui la gestion de ces foules là se
fasse avec la retenue d'avoir insisté
pour la gestion démocratique des foules
parce qu'on a bien compris l'enjeu il
s'agit de nous provoquer pour avoir des
bilans de morts ça et là pour tâcher de
ce scrutin mais ouais qu'il en est rien
on agit de la sécurité actuellement elle
est ferme mais n'a pas débordé du tout
et le scrutin je vous assure j'ai vu les
images j'ai vu le compte-rendu sur
l'ensemble du territoire se passe
normalement en dehors de quelques points
ils sont malheureusement localiser et
qui sont les fiefs des opposants ça veut
dire que fondamentalement c'est susciter
est les prochaines heures vont être à
surveiller de près par crainte d'une
flambée de violences à l'annoncé des
résultats ses prochaines 24 heures on le
rappelle l'opposition qui a appelé à la
désobéissance civile pour contrer ce
troisième mandat d'alassane ouattara
qu'elles jugent anticonstitutionnelle
on attend également d'en savoir un peu
plus en ce qui concerne le taux
d'abstention qui devrait être élevé dans
le pays puisque sur les 7,5 millions
d'électeurs inscrits 3 5 millions
disposer de leur carte d'électeur
justement on se rend dans quelques
instants
du côté de la commission électorale
indépendante pour un point presse
merci beaucoup ça monte à 1 ramsamy pour
toutes ces précisions l'opposition qui
affirme ce soir que c'est un échec du
coup d'état électoral à la fin de
citation merci ça monte à ramsamy en
direct d'abidjan